my friend Keith asked me what it's like
to be an influencer I said I didn't know
because I don't refer to myself as that
so after some research found out that
all you need to do is find some trendy
sunglasses and a chime for a pink
flamingo that are touching the truth of
these pops
[Music]
how does it feel to be in the public eye
pretty cool
[Music]
a year ago today the 21st of November
2017 I stopped drinking alcohol why
strap yourself in for one hell of a
mind-bending story this is something I
haven't really expressed before or told
many people and since this YouTube
channel is all about raw authentic real
stories here goes this video response
about honey they had no say over the
content 2005 the year youtubers founded
the year North Korea announced that of
possesses nuclear weapons Brokeback
Mountain was released the word sexting
was added to the dictionary and resource
of the year I had my very first sip of a
golden bubbly ice-cold beer frost Lord
through those awkward teen years to the
age of 18 which is the legal drinking
age in South Africa drinking became a
sport for me and in really have any
responsibilities and I wasn't really
interested in finishing school so I live
for the party let me interject here this
isn't a sob story of how I ended up in a
ditch somewhere repainting to the gods
above no this is more of an
introspective reminisce with no regrets
kind of story
cool so where were we I used to party
hard every single weekend my friends
started calling me Danny Nitro and to be
honest to this day I still don't know
why I think it's probably because I just
didn't have an off switch
eventually along with my mates got
suspended from high school for drinking
twice after that I started my life as a
filmmaker and lucky enough made a Gokul
tosh who I parted up with to start my
first business if not why not
basically I had mastered the art of
being able to drink party and make
movies at the same time as we shot all
kinds of events big small as long as
there was a party and you had enough
money to pay for a video I was there in
full flare needless to say the company
didn't make any money and we closed it
down after this I partied really hard
for a few years and made a couple films
here and there to make ends meet I was
like a much younger less successful
version of Hank Moody from fellow
using my creativity to live a life of
self-indulgence which felt great most of
the time I was never an aggressive
drinker but rather one that would become
extremely naughty by this stage of my
life after having a few toots on
different occasions I had broken both
hands my foot got my friend tooth
knocked out got beaten up a few times
gone to jail for disorderly behavior got
broken up with three times jumped onto
the main stage and face the ball got
kicked arts snack into manian got banned
from several festivals fellow for the
refund an event at Cannes Film Festival
trying to sneak girls in an inn got
taken away in a stretcher in front of
clients
I missed multiple international flights
fell into the canals in Amsterdam I just
try to kiss a guy with long hair because
the thought it wasn't go graffiti my
name on a friend's mom's house and broke
into a fast-food restaurant to make
myself an ice cream for some reason all
this [ __ ] seemed really funny you which
which it is but I hadn't yet realized
how I was selling myself short in so
many ways then just over a year ago I
was doing a documentary about finding
love in strange places and I made a guy
called Glen a 74 year old who's been
drinking every day of his life since the
age of 18 that's 56 years of active
drinking and while speaking to him about
love and other topics he told me Dan you
know that I've worked out of my lifetime
so far I've spent over $300,000 on
alcohol and now I'm left with no family
no friends no home and I'm baking at the
robots just to survive I then went home
and did some research on Glen to find
out that he was once a successful banker
that got everything taken away from him
I know this is an extreme example and
not for everyone but it hit me really
hard sitting that night on my laptop
realising three things one I alone have
spins around a hundred and twelve
thousand dollars on Oak Hall if you had
a look at that amounts in beers at the
raise of $2 a beer that's 56 thousand
beers and if looking at an Olympic
swimming pool from above that's one and
one-quarter full-sized swimming pools
over 12 years of active drinking three
times a week - my intentions weren't
matching the outcomes I was never a
person that wants to go out and break my
or ruin a reputation three drinking was
the only thing that was holding me back
from becoming a successful and respected
creative I knew that I had to stop
drinking once and for all
and this wasn't easy at first I was
counting every single day and
celebrating different benchmarks but it
became easier and easier the more I
realized how productive I became and how
I would spend my weekend surfing riding
waves and not shopping cards down a hill
a year later and everything has changed
but you're gonna have to wait for my
wrap-up end-of-the-year video to get to
get all the details but seriously I'm
not preaching here and I never want to
preach ever I went back to go visit
Glenn at the same intersection about a
week ago to find out that he's passed
away I really wanted to let him know how
much of an impact his story had on me
and how it had changed pretty much my
entire outlook and for that I thought
I'd be brave enough to share my
experience with you with that being said
if you are struggling with drinking or
gaming or drugs social media back
anything that you feel might be
impacting your life in a negative way is
these tons of help out there and this
isn't a sponsored blurb but I will put
the links to some hope lines in the
description below thank you for watching
this episode let me know your thoughts
in the comments below and don't forget
your awesome brew and I'll see you next
week Wednesday
oh wait wait and now for a cool jingle
Luke and I made for our end card a word
from responses and alive
[Applause]
did you like that cool I hope so life
update mmm lots of really exciting stuff
one the big question am I going back to
New York City what's going on what's
happening with Casey I am going back to
New York but not this year Casey's
coming down here for a holiday in a few
weeks we're gonna hang out and then next
year in February I kick off season two
right now we are busy with all the
pre-production and and I'm figuring out
how to told the most compelling story
and also figuring out what I like to
upload and what resonates most with you
merch there's still leftover merch black
t-shirts and white t-shirts so if you go
down to the link in my description and
sign up to honey you get hooked up with
a deal there tweet me a photo of your
merch if you don't have twitter DM me on
instagram I really want to see all of
you rockin the merchant board meds
before do that too and any other sort of
life updates yeah I am really happy I am
in a really good space and working
really hard into the nights but nothing
that I wouldn't want to be doing now for
the brown part of us honey honey is a
free shopping tool that automatically
searches the internet for the best promo
codes every time he's shopping for
something online it works it works on
over 30,000 sides I've used it before
for sites like ray-ban Vimeo eBay and
Groupon and today what's really rad is
it's also available on brulois comm
there's only a limited amount left and
first-come first-serve it is super
simple it only takes two clicks just go
to join honey calm forward-slash Dan
mace the average person installs honey
because the creators like me end up
saving about $30 on average that's crazy
there's literally no reason not to add
honey to your browser today it's free
and like I said before I'm gonna say it
again it only takes two clicks to
install
so click the link below in the top line
in my description or go to join honey
calm forward-slash dan mace yeah we are
done we are wrapped this is it
I really signed out of the firm
don't forget your awesome brilliant and
I'll see you next week
[Music]